dude did you see what happened with the
uh the guy who tried slashing the brake
lines to the nypd
no july i think it was july 16th or 17th
some antifa guy uh actually no let's go
back in time a little bit more
it was like july 12th or something some
antifa guy was talking to another person
and said they wanted to hurt police and
hurt the the pro-police people and stuff
like that
and so it turns out the guy's talking to
was a paid informant for the nypd
now what we don't know is whether or not
the informant became an informant once
he was told these things or was always
an informant it could be
that this antifa guy black lives matter
guy
was talking to a regular person who
panicked and then called nypd and said
yo this guy's nuts
so this guy says he wanted he was he was
trying to plot he was casing the
verrazano bridge
which the for those who don't know the
verrazano connects brooklyn and staten
island
and it is the i believe it's the largest
suspension in the country i was reading
about
it's a huge bridge they were casing it i
don't know what his plan was but he said
he wanted to disable it so that white
supremacists couldn't use it to get
you know out of staten island into
brooklyn or something like that into
brooklyn
so what ends up happening is stable he
goes with this guy this is a crazy story
he goes to this guy and they start
casing around new york trying to find
vehicles from the nypd finally they find
a van
he allegedly he gets out and tries
cutting the brake lines he actually
he apparently cut up an anti-lock brake
sensor
but the nypd was surveilling him the
whole time they got footage of it this
is what they allege whoa
so knowing what's been going on across
the country
what do you think happened to this guy
when he was arrested for this
well he was released right away
immediately without without without bail
not surprising so the feds did arrested
him immediately arrested him immediately
good
well okay no no immediately is is
exaggerated
the feds came in a couple weeks later
which was just uh just the other day
and arrested him and this is this is
crazy to me because
i was so i was covering this earlier and
i read through the affidavit from the
fbi
the fbi is my understanding and i could
be wrong gets involved when something is
is interstate they're a federal their
federal jurisdiction
if you're in a state and you commit a
crime this it's the state's jurisdiction
not the federal government's right if
you're going between states
that's when the feds come in it's it's a
brilliant system so what did this guy do
that warranted federal involvement oh
boy
nothing you know you're a good point the
fed said
what the nypd engages in interstate
commerce
and uses their vehicles to do such
really
that's it what so wait but that's how
would they arrest him for that though
because they were arresting the feds it
is my
i could be wrong about this and that's
the thing i'm not gonna pretend like i
know everything about
well this is conspiratory hour listen
listen yeah yes
absolutely listen the fbi affidavit
said we arrested him here's why we
arrested him here's a picture of the
evidence here's what he did
okay and then the last paragraph says
the nypd uses these vehicles for
interstate commerce
and and i'm like okay wait wait wait
hold on
this guy was was informed upon by an
nypd informant
arrested by new york city for crime in
new york against the nypd why is the fbi
getting involved
and the affidavit the guy's apparently
facing like 20 years
i don't know man but i'll tell you this
the nypd
it's not the nypd that released them it
was a judge that caught them loose
yeah it's always the judges yeah with
like no bail apparently
just like you're free to go sir so the
feds came in detained him and said
you're not going anywhere until trial
i bet the police are pissed about it
yeah because they're the ones arresting
them but then the judges are the ones
that let them all out
this is what's crazy to me about what's
going on right now yeah so now that now
that we're in the weird
uh conspiracy-minded space in portland
how do these people keep getting out of
jail the courts can't indict them
the grand juries won't indict them and
the judge is like in new york cutting
them loose
how do you have a guy who tries to cut a
break line for the nypd
yeah you're free to go sir no bail
required you're not just
the dude was casing the verrazano bridge
allegedly holy cow this is all the
legendary
and they're like the next day you're
free to go so the feds got involved and
that's what's crazy to me
this says to me that bill barr is
dropping the hammer
and he's not playing games here here so
the fbi
arrests this guy and says well you know
these vehicles are used for interstate
commerce therefore it's our jurisdiction
it's like huh now maybe they could get
involved maybe that's my
misunderstanding but it didn't justify
any even in
any any other way it like seemed weirdly
like it was trying to
my understanding is like maybe i could
be wrong i don't know why would the fbi
be getting involved in state level
matters
i thought it was going to say something
like this dude traveled from out of
state into new york it didn't
just the vehicles are used for these
things therefore
that's why i'm saying you know i'm
interstate commerce though i'm still
still thinking about that like what what
would the nypd be doing
if they have proof that the nypd has
used that van
for interstate commerce no the vehicles
in general just like the general
that's why i'm saying like this to me
that makes sense it just it doesn't
no what makes more sense is that the fbi
and the doj are taking it seriously yeah
these are violent extremists
they're terrorists trying to cut the
break lines that could have killed nine
police officers who were
abusive and what is allegedly
casing the verrazano bridge like what is
what is that
they're gonna blow it up what are they
gonna i don't know you know it's a
suspension bridge so if they
hit the right cables the whole thing
could crumple down like that's
that can kill thousands of people i'm
sure millions of people go over that
bridge every day these are crazy
people to be fair to be right i do want
to stress i'm i'm very much a fan of
innocence until proven guilty so
but when they were surveilling him and
watching him cut the breakouts still
it's still their allegations like okay
you show me a video of the guy doing it
and that's a different story sure even
then i'll be like is it the same guy
there's a photo you can't tell it's him
they say they show a photo of a guy
under the van
and they're making these accusations
against them here's the thing man you
know look
so what we've seen i'm not gonna say the
photo that they've given to the public
of him under the van it's in the no it's
actually the fbi for david
oh so it was submitted to the judge but
it's public record so you can see the
photo of the guy under the van wow okay
they're saying it's him
there was one of those wall of moms so
so the other day uh it was a riot in
portland
and of course they of course the
democrats and these leftists on twitter
are lying every single day non-stop
saying
now that the feds are gone everything's
peaceful it's not been true one time
yeah they just switched from the
courthouse to now the east precinct and
they're
they're trying to burn that down
residential neighborhoods and
residential areas and the
moms one of them got arrested for felony
rioting
and was released right away yeah there's
there's a video of one of those moms
that
just like trying to wild up the crowd
like we're here to f stuff up
we're here to have stuff up we're here
to have stuff up
like just like what you're wearing the
mom shirt like
you're you're for peace aren't you no
you're not that they wanna
stop that's
when the moms first appeared and their
arms were linking together and they were
like but we're just
mothers andy said i recognize many of
these women
they're anti-fuck they're they're lying
yeah it's propaganda
sure enough now that the riots are
continuing they're actually
overtly engaged in the riots wearing the
yellow shirts
yeah you know what really really really
got me angry today
really really really hanging really
really wow and i was reading about
knight 70 of the ongoing riots in
portland
and the article from oregon live had 16
instances of the word protester and i
believe
two instances no yeah and two instances
of the word demonstrators
wow in an article titled police declare
riot
and i'm like stop stop
just say it there is a weird like
cognitive dissonance
dissonance going on in the narrative of
the far left riots in extremism
yeah where it's like they're i can tell
their fingers are probably like
shaking as they type the word protester
and their eyes are twitching from
it's like it's not true but oh i have to
say it
yeah protesters they're not protesting
anything right now
no they're just trying to burn stuff
down yeah they're straight up simply
rioters period no no confusion
they're the protesters left they're
they're they don't have their shield
anymore you see who they're it's
all just antifa burning stuff rioters i
wonder why
they backed off the courthouse because
the feds did not leave there's a video
where the feds are walking around
sweeping up trash
and the left is screaming at them yeah
and the feds are just sweeping up trash
that for some reason the far leftists
antifa stopped throwing the explosives
now it was initially reported that other
protesters stopped them
that says to me they wanted the opening
for the propaganda
once it was announced by the democrats
by kate brown
that the feds were withdrawing even
though it's not true and they're still
there
all of a sudden the protesters stopped
antifa from throwing explosives
then when there was no fighting they
said oh look now there's no fighting you
see it was trump's fault meanwhile
that same day when they claimed there
was no fighting
they were there was a bunch of far
leftists uh rioting through residential
neighborhoods a hundred miles south in
springfield oregon
wow and then since then as they've been
saying see the federal courthouse is all
peaceful now it was trump's fault
the feds are still there they didn't
leave i know they're all but now
now andrew was going to residential
neighborhoods they went to some woman's
house and they physically attacked her
on her property
now mind you like we mentioned this lady
was acting a fool she was wearing a nazi
armband yeah
but you don't go to someone's property
and attack them on their property
they were they were screaming at her
take it off and it's like yo bro she's
in her own house they were blasting her
with those
lasers they were trying to they're
trying to permanently maim her
yeah this is people don't realize it man
and this lady didn't realize it
the green lasers they use will
permanently blind you yep i am not
exaggerating it's not a joke
they will hold it in your face and if
you look at it you could be blind for
the rest of your life
there's a tool that they use and they've
used for a long time called the dazzler
this is used by law enforcement it's
used in the middle east
and it's a powerful green laser they
point at your face and they click it and
and blast you and it makes you blind for
about 30 seconds
so the easiest way to explain it is like
if you've ever looked at a light
directly and then you get those spots
imagine that covered your entire field
of vision forever
forever just wiping out your ability to
see just frying your
your lens or whatever how it works it's
crazy so we use these they're weapons
and they were doing it to this woman
because they didn't like that she was
wearing an offensive piece of
an offensive garment honestly i don't
like it either i yeah exactly
i'd have no problem you know swearing at
her or something
you know what i mean i'd be like yeah
like you know what man the the problem
with a lot of these people that think
they can wear this to antagonize is they
look
they they're not doing what they think
they're doing right they're just looking
like idiots
so but you know what i'm my own business
am i going to walk up to somebody's
house and swear at him no i'm not going
to do it
if i saw somebody in public i'd be like
yeah i'm gonna
stay away from that kind of person you
know what i mean yeah you go you go do
your thing you get away from me
you wanna you wanna start trouble with
me you'll find trouble but i'm gonna i'm
gonna mind my own business
for them to go to somebody's house
here's here's what's important about
this in terms of escalation
it was never going to be something you
know ridiculous like antifa shows up
someone's house
knocks on the door and says we couldn't
help but notice the wind chimes
yeah well wind chimes actually come from
this country so prove it wasn't going to
be ridiculous
it's going to be incremented so now
they're going to say we're justified in
doing it because of what she was wearing
now the media has not where where are
the headlines
where's cnn where's any of these outlets
to be like yo don't go to people's
houses nowhere well they don't want
anyone knowing that antifa actually
exists
that's what happened yeah that's what
they've been telling everyone they can't
they can't now switch their tune because
then
it'll prove that they've been wrong for
the past two months
you know so they can't they can't switch
and now that antifa knows
they can go to someone's house and
nothing will be said
about them negative that's a good point
nothing go to anybody's house
see if the media called them out there
they would they would have defended
themselves and said well you know we
wouldn't but like look what she was
doing
now that the media's had nothing it's
like garba launch
go for it go to somebody's house yeah
they went to andy noe's house
did they yeah a while ago and they've
been threatening and intimidating him
they physically attacked him in the
street
and look they've been to tucker
carlson's house they've been to conjure
fairbanks house
they went to the politicians homes this
is terrorism dude i'm sure they don't
like
us oh definitely yeah but you know uh i
think
i i i keep i keep a lot of it to ideas
you know we both do yeah we're either
talking about the highest level
or the general concept true when you
start go when you start talking you you
name
one of these people and they'll they'll
come to your house and that's the thing
about andy
yeah he does call each and every one and
andy does
he so whenever these people get arrested
their information is public
yeah so andy reports on who the people
are what they're doing
for this they've made up insane fake
news about them and they go after them
they go to his house they attack him and
stuff like that
so but definitely you know they don't
like what we're doing
that's for sure definitely not they love
it when the media lies what was it that
video they put out where they're like
stop filming us and posting videos
because we're getting arrested yep
they're
they're basically just begging people to
please stop filming us doing what we're
doing because we're getting
people are are finding us through those
videos and arresting us
and all i can think is just like good
good riddance did you keep filming
people are gonna film it because they
want the clicks
sorry that's kind of what the society is
now people want to get those views they
want to get the shares
and you're you're the star of the show
and we're all watching you
like you're the spoiled little brat that
you are you're getting arrested
because you're rioting rioting not
protesting anymore you're writing
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 pm if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you